thank you very much Ron Corleone this
really attractive woman is my girlfriend
Lucy hello Lucy
Oh impressive handshake Thanks my father
told me that a limp handshake was for
weak men and communists he made it both
well done Tommy
zette bacon on your turkey leg they call
it a Swanson Wow now after we are given
the certificate who do you think should
speak first I think it should be me and
than you but if you want it could be you
and then me or it could go me you me
what do you think about just you thank
you Ron yes tomorrow the Parks and Rec
Department is receiving a commendation
at the Indiana State House for bringing
the Harvest Festival back and although
it's purely ceremonial it's a huge deal
for me to go to the Statehouse I
couldn't care less about the
commendation
but Indianapolis is home to Charles
Mulligan's Steakhouse the best damn
Steakhouse in the damn State I have
taken a picture of every steak I've ever
eaten there June 2004 porterhouse
medium-rare Bearnaise sauce January 2000
they call this one the enforcer February
96 a steak ribeye the whiskey Lagavulin
16 the lady next to me a [ __ ]
specifically my ex-wife Tammy okay this
is this is the first time I ever went
there oh just a kid then maybe we should
take a quick to our sojourn to Dame
kervins misshapen celebrity Castle its
where Madame Tussaud sends all of its
failed wax figures and if you can figure
out who it is you get to take it home
know what's wrong with you grouchy pants
I've been fasting all day to save room
for Mulligan's fasting is not healthy
Leslee you need to understand we are
heading for the most special place on
earth when I'm done eating a Mulligan's
meal for weeks afterwards there are
flecks of meat in my moustache and I
refuse to clean it because every now and
then a piece of meat will fall into my
mouth oh I forgot to tell you Chris
Traeger is joining us for dinner tonight
please tell me he's meeting us at the
restaurant no we are picking him up damn
it woman oh my god they just forgot to
unlock the door that's all Ron it looks
like they're closed some kind of health
code violations they just boarded her up
like she was some common warehouse I
should have been here what happened to
the steaks that were in there when they
closed do you think they got eaten why
don't we go back to my place and I'll
fire up the grill you sure you're not
expecting company or something oh you
see Ron go back to my place we'll make
you some grub maybe just as good as it
would have been here
Ron would you like some salad since I am
NOT a rabbit no I do not try it sounds
good for you
you got it mmm delicious
from what in the devil's name is this
portobello mushrooms where's the steak
well there's no steak
that's a healthier option it's
organically grown okay okay can you get
us a cold conference or something this
is a mistake why would you call it that
on your menu and I know to tell him in
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have wait wait I worry what you just
heard was give me a lot of bacon and
eggs what I said was give me all the
bacon and eggs you have do you
understand
it's rough in here is it always like
this
I wouldn't know don't like strip clubs
smells like a wet mop in here and I get
the feeling that every one of these
women is running a low-grade fever
you're one of the good ones Ron wait a
minute
hello beautiful
[Music]
strippers do nothing for me I like a
strong salt-of-the-earth self-possessed
woman at the top of her field your
Steffi Graf's your Sheryl Swoopes is but
I will take a free breakfast buffet
anytime anyplace
and I'll have the number 8 that's a
party platter that serves 12 people I
know what I'm about son all right party
time I would suggest sticking around and
watching him eat it because it only
takes four minutes and it's pretty
amazing these will not be necessary
I enjoy government functions like I
enjoy getting kicked in the Nuggets with
a steel-toed move but this hotel always
serves bacon-wrapped shrimp that's my
number one favorite food wrapped around
my number three favorite food I go to a
banquet in honor of those Somali pirates
if they serve bacon-wrapped shrimp
excuse me hey table 12 can I get a
what-what Wow thank you I mean and you
look stunning but Leslie wow I was going
for a while
you got it I was told it was black-tie I
like your hairdo Leslie thank you mom
it's just like my brother she's an
officer in the Air Force bacon-wrapped
shrimp oh thanks I'm okay I wasn't
offering this came out no I am starving
I haven't had lunch since yesterday so
I'm gonna head over to callaghan's oh no
no no don't go there they totally skimp
on pickles let me go to bighead joes for
you they have the most insane burritos I
don't much go for ethnic food no trust
me they have one that's called the meat
tornado literally killed a guy last year
you had made meat tornado beer Garth um
wasn't sticker outfit Kali was the
fourth round Indianapolis Colts know how
to draft so well they really do Andy
this was delicious it's awesome it's a
whole new meat delivery system thank you
so we say we go out to the parking lot
run a few pass plays to burn off the
calories you are an unstoppable good
idea machine I like Andy I'm surrounded
by a lot of women in this department and
that includes the
up
hey man reading the defense graduate
boner
[Laughter]
swats on what am i man are you kidding
me top of the morning everyone
I brought some burgers and fries eat up
the protein soaks up the sugar first you
take the cow to the killing floor hey
Ron thanks for coming man
of course this bowling alley has my
favorite restaurant in Pawnee really
you're not scared to eat here when I eat
it is the food that is scared would you
like to sample our vegan bacon 100%
meatless yes please another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this I don't
think I can give you any more I want one
I'm gonna get 12 eggs and part of a dead
animal dealer's choice please and thank
you
what a gorgeous herbaceous mentaly
there's been a mistake
you've accidentally given me the food
that my food eats salad is traditionally
the first course at a wedding is a
gerbil marrying a rabbit I'm in charge
of food for the wedding so I brought in
pawnees three best caterers and a panel
of experts chris loves vegetables Ron
loves meat and Tom considers himself a
foodie which apparently means taking
instagrams of food instead of eating it
so of course I remember you
your chastity right Leslie even though I
didn't invite you
you came here anyway I respect that
because you made a choice as a free
American what are you eating
I call this turf and turf it's a
16-ounce t-bone and a 24-ounce
porterhouse also whiskey and a cigar I'm
gonna consume all of this at the same
time because I am a free America the
cigars inside sir fine I will smoke the
entire thing outside even though it is
bad for me
I am going
you